this is an F-16 fighter jet since the
1970s it's been a Cornerstone of the U.S
Air Force now the US allows all these
militaries to also have f-16s and since
Russia invaded Ukraine in 2022 Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski has been
begging for them zielinski has been
doubling down on his request for NATO
Jets and they really are pleased for
Fighters yet but for Ukraine the U.S
hasn't been as generous we don't think
he needs f-16s now no he doesn't need F6
is now and that might be surprising
because the US has already given nearly
47 billion dollars in military aid to
Ukraine over the past year that's a lot
of weapons
far more than it gave even some of its
closest allies in 2020 and more than
four times what it gave Afghanistan's
Army at the height of the U.S led War
there this is a historic number that you
would see typically the US military give
to another country over decades
the U.S refusing to send f-16s is a
choice worth understanding because the
weapons that the U.S has and hasn't
chosen to send Ukraine and when they've
sent them have helped shape each phase
of this war
so what has the U.S been giving to
Ukraine and why
foreign
Russia took over Crimea and parts of
eastern Ukraine with the help of
Ukrainian separatist fighters in 2014
ragtag wouldn't even describe the state
of the Ukrainian Armed Forces this is
Jack detch foreign policies U.S national
security reporter they'd been gutted by
years of neglect a lot of the troops
didn't have uniforms some of them didn't
have hot food Ukraine's leaders asked
the U.S for help but President Barack
Obama only sent protective gear and
supplies not weapons in 2018 president
Donald Trump agreed to send a limited
number of anti-tank missiles called
javelins but the Ukrainian Army was
still woefully unprepared if Russia
decided to escalate the conflict which
it did
in 2022 Russia launched a full-scale
invasion of Ukraine
Russian Jets and missiles were doing
immense damage from the air and Russian
tanks were pushing Ukraine's troops
backwards Ukraine again asked the U.S
for help from the beginning of the war
the ukrainians wanted a lot of the
things that you see on the menu right
now they wanted f-16s they wanted main
battle attacks so they wanted this stuff
from the get-go President Joe Biden
agreed to send a large package of
weapons but it mainly included the
smaller and relatively unsophisticated
kinds the U.S sent more javelins plus
ammunition guns and even some
anti-aircraft missiles called stingers
and many U.S allies sent similar types
of weapons
Germany sent a thousand anti-tank
missiles and 500 Stingers Belgium sent 2
000 machine guns but no one sent their
advanced battle tanks or fighter jets
the main question in the beginning of
the war was not just what the US was
going to send I mean the question was
like are these guys gonna fight
certainly that's been a resounding yes
Ukraine soldiers used anti-aircraft
missiles to prevent Russian aircraft
from controlling the skies and they used
the gun's ammo and anti-tank weapons to
Halt Russia's progress
like in this video which shows Ukrainian
soldiers destroying dozens of Russian
tanks approaching Kiev
but even though the ukrainians were
using these weapons well the U.S
hesitated to send it more advanced
equipment so the US has been concerned
that almost every step about the
potential for Russia escalating the
conflict the U.S word that Ukraine might
use some of these Advanced weapons like
fighter jets or long-range missiles to
strike inside Russia sparking and
escalation this concern would come to
Define how the U.S supplied Ukraine
in the spring of 2022 the war entered
its second phase
Russia and Ukraine's armies weren't
moving as much anymore and instead began
pounding each other with artillery
Russia was firing a staggering 60 000
rounds a day while Ukraine could only
manage to fire around six thousand and
it was quickly running low but the U.S
was still hesitating to expand the scope
of its support
they're looking at what's kind of on the
Christmas wish list and deciding what's
actually prudent to give finally in
April 2022 the US agreed to send Ukraine
its own artillery
and like in the first phase of the war a
number of allies then sent their own
artillery even though some had wanted to
do it earlier
you sort of saw it folks in Europe
wanting the US to lead but sometimes the
U.S still very much Deep In The
Liberation mode the most important
weapon the U.S sent were called highmars
powerful rocket launchers that could hit
targets as far as 80 kilometers they
weren't powerful enough to strike inside
Russia but they did enable Ukraine to
hit Russian Supply Depots and command
posts far behind its front lines which
forced the Russians to move them back
weakening its troops at the front
that's how Ukraine captured the hardcave
region in September and the major city
of Curson in November
and by then a new phase was beginning
in Winter 2023 both sides were planning
new attacks Russia was gearing up to
push further into the Donetsk and
luhansk regions but Ukraine also wanted
to take back territory particularly in
the south in order to do this Ukraine
would need to move troops quickly which
requires armored vehicles like tanks
something it had been asking for for
months some countries had sent older
models tanks but just like with
artillery the US waited
they wanted the Germans to act close by
sending leopard battle tanks the Germans
were waiting for the United States to
give them some political cop cover here
a little bit of a game of chicken
finally in January 2023 the UK and then
the U.S agreed to send their Advanced
tanks prompting Germany and several
allies to follow with their best battle
tanks just like with anti-tank missiles
and highmars before the U.S and its
allies are hoping that these tanks can
push Ukraine to win some decisive
victories in this phase which is where
we are now it's the ukrainians kind of
can't turn the tide turn the balance
right now it's it's going to be tricky
to see you know how this doesn't go into
its an extent it's stalemate that's why
Ukraine is still asking for fighter jets
f-16s could protect Ukraine's tanks from
Russian aircraft making their attack
much more powerful
Ukraine has also been asking the US for
long-range missiles called attackums
which it could use to strike Russian
positions as far as 300 kilometers
behind their lines
already a few allies are in favor of
sending these weapons but as of this
video the US is hesitating over familiar
concerns questions about their their
Readiness for trading on those also of
course you know just just the question
again how far are the ukrainians going
to fire these days so far none of the
decisions to send any of these weapons
has inspired Russia to escalate and in
March Poland and Slovakia agreed to send
some of their older fighter jets making
the eventual approval of f-16s or
long-range missiles more of a
possibility
but after giving Ukraine over 46 billion
dollars in military aid public opinion
in the U.S is changing a recent Pew
research poll showed the portion of
people who believed the US has sent too
much Aid to Ukraine has grown
particularly on the right Biden facing a
lot of pressure not only within his
party but of course from Republican
Rivals getting ready for the 2024 debate
stage that's going to make it much more
difficult for President Biden to sustain
this clip and even if Biden maintains
popular support to send weapons he might
not have enough a recent analysis found
that certain supplies may be approaching
the minimal level that the US requires
for its own War planning
it's why the U.S is now focusing on ways
to increase production of weapons at
home in Allied countries and in Ukraine
but just building those plants could
take years
one year of U.S and Allied support has
helped transform the Ukrainian Army into
a formidable Force whose soldiers have
repeatedly held its ground against a
much larger Russian army
but with both the battlefield and U.S
politics changing the questions now are
how well is Ukraine going to fight with
what they have and how much more U.S
help can they count on
[Music]
thanks for watching this episode of Vox
Atlas Vox has been covering the war in
Ukraine since it began with in-depth
explainers and Analysis you can find all
our coverage of the war at vox.com
Ukraine
[Music]
foreign